foreign
of the day comes from Sarah in Virginia
here's what Sarah's asking I'm a 23 year
old that graduated college in May of
2022 and I got a job at a non-profit
making 45k a year I live with my parents
and plan on staying there until I can
buy a home I have no debt no bills and
have an inheritance of 75 000 sitting in
a savings account doing nothing my
parents are very against credit cards
and truly believe cash is King I agree
but I also think I should get a credit
card to build credit and get cash back
points Etc I'm wondering if you have any
advice on what to do with the
inheritance that's sitting there the
money that I'm making and if I should
get a credit card I would love to invest
in real estate but would love to hear
from you first
well Sarah uh thanks for the question it
sounds like you got a lot going on a lot
of different questions let's tackle the
first Numero Uno question what to do
with this 75k hey if it's me you have no
debt I'm making sure that I've got three
to six months of expenses right George
that's thing one my guess is maybe she
does if she's been living at home but if
she doesn't if you don't have other
savings we need to take a portion of
that and allocate it to an emergency
fund correct and then if that's the case
or let's say you already had your
savings I'm looking at a down payment
George I'm trying to get up out of the
parents basement not to say that you're
living in the basement I'm just saying
I'm trying to get out of my parents
house at this point and see about life
on my own and maybe that's uh an
apartment at first because you know if
you have no debt and you have no credit
history like George George made a very
good point earlier about making sure
that you've established credit history
with um your parents as renters
so to speak in that you're actually
paying rent to your parents so when it's
time to get a mortgage they can actually
look at those payment histories as a way
to do some manual underwriting I'll let
George explain that but that's first
thing that I'm thinking is let me get
out of my parents house and uh so George
why don't you talk to that real estate
question a little bit as far as
investing oh the manual underwriter yeah
okay the underwriting so part of your
question is do I get the credit card to
build a credit and get the cash back you
don't need to play that game at all Jade
and I have both gotten mortgages with no
credit history no credit score because
once we got out of debt the credit score
disappears into the abyss that's right
it becomes you don't miss it zero and so
you go well indeterminable what does the
lender do then well they do what's
called a no score loan manual
underwriting a lot of lenders actually
do this you just have to do your
research and our friends at Churchill
Mortgage have been doing this forever
and uh here's what you want to do get in
touch with them to figure out what this
looks like for you living at home you
you need to have some kind of rental
history that's a fact which means you
need to have been paid your parents a
sum of money consistently around the
same time every single month for one
year and it needs to be a sum that makes
sense for instance before Sam and I
bought our first house we did rent from
his mom she owned a property we rented
but we paid a reasonable rent she I
think she rented to us at Cost but every
month we wrote her a check for twelve
hundred dollars and so we were able to
use that as our uh rental history and so
that was able to work for us zero credit
score and there may be other history of
payments they want to look at like your
cell phone bill so you said you have no
bills I would just get more clarity on
that so that you're not shocked a year
from now but if you are going to be
buying a home I'd have a clear timeline
I wouldn't just continue living at home
with Mom and Dad for the foreseeable
future until you feel like it I would
say hey one year from now my goal is to
move out I want to start making payments
to you guys so I have rental history and
I have some skin of the game start
paying some bills around here and then
one year from now I'm going to continue
saving that inheritance can go sit in a
high heel savings account because you've
got a short-term goal so we don't want
to invest this money into the market
when we need this money that's right in
the next few years she's also talking
about in real investing in real estate
George
Le there's a lot of aspiring Real Estate
Investors out there in their 20s and I
love that and we love real estate around
here but there's a time and place for it
and it is once you've got a primary
residence paid off you're in baby steps
seven no debt in the world then save up
and pay cash for Real Estate then and
only then and it reduces risk it
increases your cash flow which is what
it's all about right reduces your stress
from being a landlord at 23 while trying
to get out there as an adult there's
just there's a lot going on in your life
and you don't need to be a real estate
investor tomorrow yeah let's take it one
thing at a time you can build wealth
without that and so I would just focus
on increasing your income that might and
it sounds like you love the non-profit
space that's great if you want to stay
there if you want to move to the private
sector you might you know double your
income depending on what you're doing
and then the credit cards you just
simply don't need you've survived this
along without them and you're doing
great you're doing so much better than
most people who have credit cards and so
what does that tell you about wealth
building credit cards under a part of
the game
they're not a part of it there you go
well thanks for the the question Sarah
there's a lot packed in there thinking
about the right things and I I have a
lot of faith in Sarah that she's going
to build wealth quickly at this age